after months of speculation alien
covenant has finally been unleashed upon
the world and all its gory glory
whatever your feelings are about the
return to the franchise there are still
some considerable inconsistencies in the
story to discuss
that's why we've rounded up some plot
holes that you could fit a chest burster
through but before you keep watching
just be aware there are major spoilers
ahead so please tread carefully not like
that guy that guy's dead not so handy
alien covenants big plot twist at the
end comes with the reveal that it's
actually the nefarious David aboard the
ill-fated covenant not his kinder
synthetic brother Walter in order for
David to effectively fool the surviving
crew he must assume Walters identity
completely and that includes cutting off
his hair and one of his hands
Walter notably lost his own hand while
protecting Daniels earlier in the film
but something about that doesn't
completely add up when Walter and David
Duke it out on the surface of the planet
we learned that Walters been built with
self-healing technology allowing him to
recover from being fatally stabbed in
the neck so if he can recover from
mortal injuries in minutes why can't he
heal a dismembered limo over the course
of the film
sure regrowing a hand is probably tough
but so it's coming back from the dead
safety first sci-fi and action films
have caused us to become accustomed to
watching smart characters too incredibly
dumb things for our entertainment and
alien covenant is no exception from Orem
sticking his head somewhere no
reasonable person would ever want to
approach to the crew following David
into the cave of nightmares he calls a
home the movie is loaded with
maddeningly stupid moments but the
decision that stands out among all the
others is the one that sees the entire
crew not bothering the dawn helmets once
they've landed on the engineers planet
this is a foreign unstudied ecosystem
and there's no guarantee the humans will
be able to or even should breathe the
air there the lack of protective gear
leaves a pretty convenient entry point
to the desk pours into unsuspecting
characters ears and noses but logically
speaking nobody would set foot on an
uncharted planet without first making
sure they were completely protected from
the elements even if the biggest threat
is basically the world's worst pollen
allergy what came first it's very
clearly established in aliens that the
Queen lays the eggs both very simple and
very
gross but the overcomplicated
explanations for the creatures
beginnings first introduced in
prometheus are further built upon here
alien covenant revealed it was actually
david who created them in the first
place
dr. frankenstein style ten years in
isolation makes a man do weird things
with eggs but how did he engineer them
without the queen did he create the
queen - is he the creator of all alien
life-forms or just some david spends
years crossbreeding the neo morphs in
pursuit of a more perfect organism and
by the end of alien covenant we see the
familiar xenomorph the end result of all
that experimentation but as the events
of alien took place about 20 years later
how did the space jockey ship in that
movie end up being filled of eggs the
more we learn about this mythology the
less sense it makes pod people problems
the catalyst for alien covenants ongoing
nightmare is an energy search which
forces the ship's crew out of hyper
sleep early unfortunately not everybody
makes it out of their sleep pods in time
and captain Jacob Branson catches on
fire and dies no feeling good I'm
starting up but what actually happened
to his pod did it just malfunction did
it have something to do with the energy
search can they maybe invent a pod that
doesn't double as a barbecue or did
covenant just want to give a little gift
the audience in the form of James
Franco's smoldering corpse I mean I have
a very good life either way thank you
movie thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]